now a special look at thor ragnarok now
i know what you're thinking how does
this happen
long story a cow is dead
[Music]
some buy this
what if we were today children a
contender
you
[Music]
and now I
we know each other is a friend from work
happy Monday everybody new thor ragnarok
most of the footage is the same you get
a little better look at that ricky baker
easter egg from hunt for the Wilderland
deadpool - i'll explain that in a second
but because spider-man is getting ready
to come out I'm still doing the ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video I think what they're doing with
this is they're getting ready to drop a
new trailer with spider-man homecoming
and they're bringing Thor to Comic Con
so really the bigger part of this video
is the Marvel comic con plans because
only Marvel DC and Fox you know with all
the x-men universe stuff are bringing
footage to Comic Con all the other
studios are probably going to bail but
aren't comic book movies the only movies
that you come to comic-con to see
footage from the Ricky Baker Deadpool
two things so if you look at the
graffiti behind Thor here it says skux
life that's New Zealand slang for thug
life Julien Denison the actors that
played Riki Baker in Thai car WA td's
film hunt for the wilderkin Deadpool -
as an unknown character we don't know if
he's playing somebody from the comics
but it's a nice Marvel crossover because
he was a great character if you haven't
seen that I'd recommend you check it out
it's not a comic book film but it is the
job that helped icon what TV get thor
ragnarok sam neill also stars in it and
there's a rumor that he has a part in
thor ragnarok - but it sounds like it
might be a pretty small cameo but the
important stuff news or bragging arak
obviously this is the next big movie
that's coming out for Marvel so that's
what their big presentation is going to
be at Comic Con they showed up all kinds
of footage last year at Comic Con for
movies that were way off so expect the
same treatment this year the panel is
going to be Saturday night like it is
every year so Thor Ragnarok I'm not
expecting them to bring new spider-man
because they'll have already released
that movie worldwide and they're already
a couple movies that are coming up so
they might bring Tom Holland just to
give them a shout out but there's not
going to be a big spider-man
presentation Black Panther is the next
big movie they'll show off more footage
from that and then the really big thing
you're asking about infinity war footage
they'll finally show off the first
teaser for infinity war so uh well you
know we've got
knows
[Applause]
what they might do is they might not
release it publicly because they clamp
down hardcore on that they did the same
thing with guardians of the galaxy last
year James Gunn brought guardians to
footage they had ego the Living Planet
in it it showed you all the stuff that
was in that first trailer it just didn't
have any of the finished CG so it didn't
look that cool so that's why he didn't
want to release it publicly so just be
prepared for the same thing to happen
with infinity war but whatever ends up
happening I'll totally do a video for it
if there's super banning footage I'll
still try to do a video and I'll try to
find a way around that I kind of had to
do that last year with guardians 2 and
with spider-man very well it's going
very well and every day there are shots
there are images that are pairing of
characters you've never seen before on
screen that again I'm very lucky to do
what I do I'm very thankful to do what I
do and I do it because I get out for
these moments I kick out for a moment
like this debuting a movie of spider-man
in the MCU for the first time on
infinity war every single shot of every
single scene it's a geek out moment
that's not the end of it though they
have a man in the wasps coming up the
director was teasing a big reveal
they'll probably show off the wasp
costume they said they've redesigned it
a little bit but you got that teaser at
the end of the last ant-man movie it'll
be based on that they have confirmed
that Janet Van Dyne is going to be in
the movie so they might show some
concept footage off for her as well
Captain Marvel is so far off I'm not
expecting a whole lot from that but they
might bring brie Larson back out on
stage to wave at everybody and they
might announce what's going on with Nick
Fury in that universe there's a lot of
rumors about Nick Fury showing up in the
film he is classic military even though
he's been shield for a long time he was
a howling commando so it makes sense
it's more military themed Marvel
characters would show up in that like
war machine might show up during Captain
Marvel because they did have a romance
in the comics and it sounds like they're
mostly going to be dealing with her
origin story and her powers in that
movie because it's sandwiched between
the Avengers films so you have infinity
war that's when the character debuts
then you have the Captain Marvel movie
then you have Avengers 4 they always get
super in theatrical they might do
another version of that Loki Comic Con
experience way back the year after
Avengers came out but before Thor the
world was released they had to do that
special presentation humanity
it was probably the best Comic Con
presentation that I've ever seen and
they haven't really done something like
that since then so they might have a
little bit of fun with Tom Hiddleston
again but the thing about thor ragnarok
it's a little bit different with his
character is that he achieved the goal
that he wanted to he's king of Asgard
but the way they explain hella is that
she breaks out because he's actually
really shitty at his job and he in Thor
don't even talk to each other
Chris Hemsworth said it's a bit of a
funny twist on their relationship
because in the first Thor movie the
second Thor movie Thor would get really
pissed he tried to stop Loki from being
an [ __ ] but now it's like yeah you
know whatever just do whatever you want
they're mostly concerned with finding
Odin getting Thor out of the arena off
the car with the Hulk well let me know
in the comments what are you most hype
about for comic-con I think really
everybody is just waiting for that first
Infinity Ward trailer so because it's
such a big deal Marvel might break
tradition and actually release some of
that to the public but just be prepared
for them to not drop things besides Thor
and Black Panther so there's always the
whole aged footage that they don't show
to anybody else just because it's super
raw then there's the public stuff they
release they'll be at least Thor and
Black Panthers stuff but what's going to
happen next is this new game of Thrones
there's new spider-man and there's new
flash costume they're changing the
costume a little bit in season 4 so I'll
probably do a video for that I'm waiting
to find out a little bit more about DC's
Comic Con presentation before I do video
about that but obviously they're
bringing Justice League footage leave
all your comic-con video requests in the
comments below I will do a Marvel TV
Comic Con video just because that's like
a whole separate thing they have a ton
of defender stuff they're going to be
bringing along with the other TV shows
but congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner dart game oh one please
private message me so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything click here for new infinity
war and click here for my spider-man
homecoming with you thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see
tonight